[Musique]
pierre conissa bonjour bonjour Nous vous
interrogons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
Youtube qui s'appelle Serview on vous a
déjà reçu sur les les politiques de
contrreeradicalisation et nous nous
sommes attardés un petit peu sur votre
livre qui s'appelle guide du Paradis
publicité comparé des au-delà qui nous a
fait rire qui nous a instruit qui nous a
fait cogité et et on a trouvé ça
tellement sympa qu'on l'a terminé et on
a on pourrait Comper comparer cette cet
ouvrage nous dans notre langage internet
un un un Lonely Planet ou un trip
advisor ou un guide du routard du
Paradis mélangé avec la pointe d'humour
le cynisme de George Carline et et et
c'est déjà pas mal pierre connaisa
racontez-moi un petit peu la gèse de ce
livre ce livre a déjà quelques années
derrière lui et il est parti de constat
que qui tenait à mes activités de
stratège quoi col ouais ouais tu veux
que je le ferme ou non non juste le col
qui ah d'accord ok c'est pas allezas
donc donc je recommence donc ce livre a
déjà quelques années derrière lui il est
il était parti de mes constats de à
l'époque où je travaillais sur les
affaires stratégique qui était un
constat de bon sens c'est-à-dire que
toutes les grandes religions étaient
atteintes par des formes de
radicalisation et en général toutes ces
radicalisation avait comme comment dire
promesse commune le fait de garantir
l'accès au paradis et puis ensuite il y
a eu la guerre en Irak et alors sur la
guerre en Irak je me suis posé une
question qui est en fait une question de
bon sens c'est-à-dire comme chacun des
deux camps se battait au nom de Dieu
rappelez-vous George bouche parlait du
une croisade et qu'en face on avait
effectivement des gens qui sont
mobilisés essentiellement sur le fait de
la l'anticroisade c'est-à-dire sur le
jjihad euh je me suis dit mais
finalement les américains tués par les
iraakiens vont-ils au paradis des
chrétiens ou dans l'enfer des musulmans
et inversement et la question est
légitime parce que quand même on peut
pas commencer une guerre sans avoir
répondu à cette question donc je me suis
dit mais depuis le temps que les hommes
se foutent sur la gueule pour expliquer
qu'ils ont le Dieu unique et
miséricordieux la seule manière de
rendre compatible toutes ces théories
c'est de dire qu'il y a plusieurs dieux
uniques et c'est effectivement la seule
explication logique de la description
différente des paradis dans les
différentes
religions et donc je me suis dit mais si
c'est l'endroit où on va passer le plus
de temps parce que c'est quand même la
vie éternelle il vaut mieux se
renseigner sur les caractéristiques de
chacun des paradis parce que si on
hérite bêtement de la religion de ses
parents on se retrouve orienté à la fin
de sa vie mais sans avoir fait la
comment dire l'évaluation du marché si
on considère que la seule loi
effectivement respectée par toutes les
religions c'est la loi du marché donc
que la main invisible d'Adam Smith est
probablement la main de Dieu je me suis
dit il faut que le consommateur se
renseigne et donc j'ai essayé de
déécrire ce bouquin c'est-à-dire
finalement qu'est-ce qui différencie
tous ces paradis quel est le meilleur
moyen d'accéder à celui-là plutôt qu'à
celui-là et puis surtout si vous voulez
c'est un paysage économique extrêmement
intéressant parce qu'il y a un duopole
hein qui est grosso modo le
christianisme et l'islam il y a une une
PME très identifiée qui est le paradis
juif qui pratiquement sanctuarisé qui
donc ne ne cherche pas à mordre sur les
deux autres et puis il y a un marché de
start-up formidable qui est celui des
sectes qui continuellement se renouvelle
avec des promesses nouvelles avec des
explications nouvelles avec des messis
nouveaux et donc je me suis dit
effectivement ça vaut la peine de faire
le tour du marché vous êtes penché un
petit peu sur l'église de sciantologie
ah ben bien sûr oui bien sûr parce que
justement le le marché se renouvelle par
les sectes c'est ça qui aujourd'hui est
le paysage le plus mouvant le sectarisme
touchant tout aussi bien la religion
juive que l'islam ou que le
christianisme simplement les différences
c'est que dans le christianisme et dans
la religion et dans le la pratique
sunnite de l'Islam il y a dans la
pratique chiide de l'Islam il y a des
hiérarchies religieuses tandis que dans
les autres il y en a pas donc c'est
toujours très difficile de les qualifier
de secte parce que en fait ces religions
le sunisme et le judaïsme se sont
toujours habitué à ce qu'il y a des gens
qui tout à coup s'annoncent comme le
Messie et fassent une nouvelle développe
une nouvelle pratique mais il reste que
quand on utilise la sociologie des
sectes on se rend compte
qu'effectivement c'est un renouvellement
du marché par une promesse
perpétuellement nouvelle dont justement
l'église de scientologie don l'Ordre du
Temple solaire dont Jim Jones syana et
cetera et donc je me suis dit bon moi
mon bouquin ça ress au consommateur
occidental donc pour pas qu'il soit déçu
et qu' là se comment dire s'égarer dans
des sectes comme le bouddhisme
l'indouisme qui ont pas de bureau de
représentation ici si on est déçu par ce
genre de démarche on il y a plus de
moyen de se plaindre après donc je dis
restons sur l'offre telle qu'elle est
structuré aujourd'hui c'està-dire sur
les grandes religions présentes sur le
territoire français y compris le le
phénomène sectaire voilà donc j'ai
essayé de faire ça comme comme un guide
de voyage c'est-à-dire ben ma fois
connaître le marché connaître les
caractéristiques de chacune des offres
comment y aller comment gagner des miles
gratuits et cetera et vous posez 10
questions
h on en choisit une ou n'importe
laquelle n'importe laquelle euh comment
s'y rendre ah ça c'est une question de
localisation en géographique parce que
d'abord il faut effectivement faire le
choix d'abord choisir évidemment le
paradis qui correspond plus à ses moyens
et à ses goûts bon euh vous voyez par
exemple dans le Paradis bouddhiste
théoriquement la fin du processus
devient une espèce de monde où on a plus
aucune envie bon si c'est ça le paradis
qu'on attend il faut mieux le savoir
donc laissons tomber ce genre de
religion par contre il y a des religions
qui ont des offres très comment dire
très précisément définies compris le en
particulier l'offre musulmane et donc je
me suis dit une fois qu'on a choisi le
site la question vient ensuite
c'est-à-dire d'où partir parce que
évidemment comme toujours il y a se pose
toujours des question de lieu de lieu
adéquat au départ bon alors première
remarque que je fais c'est d'abord il
faut éviter les gros départ c'est-à-dire
c'est pour les départs en weekend B oui
en particulier les massacres et les
génocides parce que là il y a des
risques d'encombrement donc il faut
mieux partir en ayant choisi le moment
deuxième chose il faut choisir le lieu
alors il y a un problème de hub ce qui
est quand même Jérusalem c'estàd tout le
monde revendique Jérusalem comme le lieu
de départ parfait pour aller directement
au
paradis il y a quand même quelques
points de départ secondairire parce que
comme tous les grands aéroports comme
Dubaï Jérusalem est encombré par le
nombre de gens qui viennent là pour
mourir bon il y a des des points départ
secondaire selon la nature de la
religion qu'on choisit ça va être la mec
ça va être lourde ça va être je sais pas
moi carbala pour les chit et cetera donc
c'est quand même important par ça permet
de garantir et surtout les sectes ont
l'avantage de diversifier
considérablement le point de départ
puisque les sectes ayant jamais réussi
véritablement à déborder si vous voulez
sur la surface de la planète garantis un
lieu de départ de proximité et ça c'est
quand même important parce que si vous
êtes à proximité du point de départ au
moins vous savez que le corps alors le
corps n'a pas trop à se dé placer alors
il y a un truc qui m'a paru très
intéressant quand même c'est que
notamment à
Jérusalem je sais plus quel secte juif
radical avait demandé qu'on déplace
l'aéroport de de TelAviv parce que
l'aéroport de TelAviv passait au-dessus
d'un cimetière traditionnel juif bon ce
qui laisse penser qu'effectivement les
corps partent directement à la verticale
avec le risque de télescopage de l'avion
et c'est intéressant parce que ce départ
à la verticale c'est les méthodes les
plus modernes de lancement de missile
hein c'est ici Laer c'estd lancement
vertical parce que ça permet de partir
dans toutes les directions donc ça veut
dire qu'effectivement là il y a en tout
cas un saut technologique intéressant
bon je crois pas que les autorités
israélien est finalement décidé de
déplacer l'aéroport
alors les cas particulier peut-être sur
les points de départ non obsédé sexuel
parlons ah cas particulier pour des
profils différents ou oui je pens cas
particulier de point de départ diff bah
oui parce que beaucoup de questions se
posent quand
même je dis pas ça parce que c'est en ce
moment c'est l'affaire des SK mais on
sait jamais non non non non je comprends
non non ça c'est la sexualité DSK est
pas un cas particulier la sexualité est
largement traitée dans l'Ancien
Testament je dire Salomon il en avait
600 des femmes donc visiblement je sais
pas si DSK atteint ces chiffr là mais
Mahomet avait officiellement je crois
quatre femmes mais en fait il y en avait
neuf qui vivaient autour de lui donc
encore une fois c'est pas le le cas
desas est plutôt normé si vous voulez
c'est pas la question euh le bah
oui euh les histoires de l'Ancien
Testament sont à mourir de rire je veux
dire le type qui je je sais plus je
crois que c'est Jacob ou Abraham je me
souviens plus enfin il fait sa femme
ayant 90 ans ayant pas pu avoir
d'enfants lui propose sa son esclave
avec laquelle il y a des enfants et
cetera et finalement sa femme décide
finalement accouche le fils de sa femme
devient Israël et le fils de son de son
esclave devient Ismaël et vous
connaissez les problème de d'héritage
qui ont succédé puisque finalement
chacun se dispute la paternité bon entre
juif et musulman non non la question qui
m'avait occuper c'est quand même en
fonction de la nature des prestations
qui sont offertes se pose des questions
par exemple dans dans le Paradis
musulman si vous êtes un handicapé dans
la vie est-ce que vous arrivez entier
euh si vous êtes vous mourrez à 95 ans
est-ce que pour honorez les 72 vierges
vous retrouvez vos capacités de 20 ans
ou pas euh est-ce que bon dans le
Paradis chrétien la question se pose pas
parce que finalement quand on regarde
les représentations du Paradis ou de la
fin des temps dans le par exemple dans
les peintures du moyen-âge on a
l'impression que les types sortent de la
tombe àublé de chasu bleu blanche qui
les fait ressembler à des endives et
donc c'est vraiment pas le la situation
sexuelle qui va les préoccuper une fois
qu'ils sont au paradis bon donc voyez
alors la question que je me suis posé
c'est justement comment traiter des cas
particuliers qui sont les bisexuels les
transsexuels les homosexuels les
handicapés et cetera et finalement on
s'aperçoit que il y a beaucoup de de
réponses assez différentes donc il faut
chacun traiter son cas parce que je vais
pas donner tous les trucs quand même qui
sont les résultat de longues recherches
est-ce qu'il y en avait un particulier
qui vous préoccupait cé le cas des
homosexuels non ou pas euh pourquoi pas
oui ben le cas des homosexuels il y en
avit un que je trouvais très amusant qui
était quand même le le problème de la
destruction de Sodome et Gomorre dans
l'Ancien Testament bon vous savez que
Sodome et gomor étaient donc les deux
villes qui étaient des villes soit
consacré à l'homosexualité féminine soit
à l'homosexualité masculine bon
finalement Dieu décide de détruire ces
deux villes et il envoie l'archange
Gabriel qui est le messager en général
de des bonnes et des mauvaises nouvelles
donc parce que il a découvert que les
deux seuls justes en fait le seul juste
de la des deux villes c'était lotte et
donc il veut
sauver la famille lotte et sa famille
et euh donc quand l'archange arrive
immédiatement les mecs de de Sodome en
particulier voi que le type est pas mal
enfin que L'Arcange est pas mal ils
veulent se le faire et
l'utre propose pour les calmer sa fille
c'est quand même pas mal je dire c'est
un grand geste de mensuétude de sa part
bon comme ils sont homosexuels
finalement il laisse tomber et puis donc
une fois qu'il a appris la nouvelle que
les villes va détruite donc il s'en va
il quitte la
ville sa femme comme toujours dans les
monothéismes toujours insoumise toujours
incapable toujours capable de provoquer
des dégâts se retourne en dépit de de la
de l'interdit divin et finalement en se
retournant elle est transformé en statut
de selle bon le problème c'est comme il
est le dernier homme vivant sur Terre
avec ses deux filles la question qui
n'est jamaisl jusqu'à son terme c'est
finalement comment se renouvelle
l'espèce puisque il est le seul
survivant avec deux enfants qui sont les
siens et l'Ancien Testament explique que
à ce moment-là ces filles sachant qu'il
fallait renouveler l'espèce le drogue
pour le violer pour avoir des enfants de
lui bon des mauvais esprit pourrai
penser que c'est une légitimation de la
pédophilie et de l'inceste quand même
c'est un peu scandaleux de le penser
comme ça mais ça laisse quand même
planer des doutes bon donc voyez il y a
à la fois la condamnation de
l'homosexualité mais en même temps si la
condamnation de l'homosexualité passe
par la pédophilie on peut ou par
l'inceste on peut se poser des questions
sur la bonne interprétation du texte je
vais vous poser une question est-ce que
vous avez discuté un petit peu avec les
les responsables de ces PME est-ce que
vous avez discuté avec les commerciaux
non d'abord parce que moi j'avais une
formation religieuse ensuite parce que
j'ai fait d'études d'histoire donc j'ai
surtout essayé de voir l'évolution de
ces religions parce que la
caractéristique de ces grands
monothéismes dont les vistros quand même
disaient qu'ils avaient fait faire un
énorme pas à l'intolérance he quand même
puisque chacune de ces monothéismes
expliquait principe premier mon Dieu est
le bon le seul ce qui est quand même pas
la bonne manière de discuter avec les
autres donc la question c'est que une
fois que le texte saint est défini et
chacune de ses religions à le sien le
rôle important c'est celui des exégèes
des exges c'est c'estàd d'expliquer que
ce ce texte contient tout et donc il
faut y trouver la réponse à toute
situation et donc ces exégettes qui soi
hiérarchie religieuse qui soi imam qui
soit grande mosquée àazar qui soit le
sangidrain peu importe ont tous fait des
efforts intellectuels extraordinaires
pour expliquer qu'en fait il y avait
réponse à tout dans les texte donc c'est
j'ai pas discuté avec eux j'ai beaucoup
plus me suis beaucoup plus intéressé à
ces différents avatars qui tout au long
de leur histoire avaient permis de dire
une chose et son contraire là où c'est
devenu beaucoup plus intéressant c'est
que les sectes étaient d'abord il y a eu
deux révolutions la première c'est
évidemment les sectes qui encore une
fois diversifient considérablement
l'offre renouvelle considérablement la
vision du Paradis le moyen d'y accéder
et
cetera parce que dans les sectes il y a
quand même les sectes uhologiques
c'estàd les sectes P quand même il RA
donc là il là il vous garantit il vous
garanti alors ce qui est intéressant
dans le casre Rael c'est que ce type
avait un passé
de pilote de course et en fait il n'a
jamais utiliser ses super pouvoirs pour
gagner une course donc il faut saluer
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de l'homme
parce que finalement on aurait pu penser
que à lui tout seul il était capable
dans toutes les cas de causees
d'utiliser ses super pouvoirs bon mais
lui effectivement il expliquait qu'il
avait été donc enlevé par des petits
hommes vert je sais pas si c'était vert
ou d'autre couleur mais enfin en tout
cas il avait été élevé par enlever et
que donc on lui avait appris les super
pouvoirs avec lesquels il a constitué sa
secte et donc il il a dénoncé la la
comment dire la législation française
interdisant les manipulation génétique
parce qu'il disait on a la possibilité
de créer une race des super hommes le
dernier qui avait essayé les super
hommes c'était Hitler si je me souviens
bien mais enfin lui était pas il avait
pas parlé des petits hommes verts donc
si vous voulez il y a toutes ces sectes
de types qui prétendent que les secoupes
volantes les petits hommes verts et
cetera alors les sectes sont très
intéressantes parce qu'en le général
elles sont passées au stade de
l'Internet est-ce que est-ce que vous
pensez Google est une secte Google ou
non pourquoi Facebook non non non non
non je crois qu'il faut pas confondre là
les sectes c'est vraiment un gourou un
type qui a un discours aussi
extraordinaire qu'il soit et surtout une
forme d'organisation sociale qui est une
emprise totale sur la communauté avec un
discours vous décrivez Google ah
pourquoi Google Google avec son leader
qui veut améliorer la race humaine qui
ah ça je sais pas j'ai pas suivi ben
peut-être qu'il faut l'inclure maisc mon
texte il est d'ancien il est de 2004 à
l'époque Google avait pas une rle un
rôle aussi important mais si surtout les
sectes ont développer le la pratique
d'internet on le voit avec les
salafistes aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que
là on a la possibilité de faire le tour
de l'offre sans trop se bouger et puis
surtout même dans les grands
monothéismes il y a de plus en plus de
communication par Internet interposé ou
par télévision interposé par exemple les
téléprédicateurs américains sont de
formidables entreprises commerciales où
le type vous promet le paradis bien
évidemment souvent des fois il vous
annonce même la date de la fin du monde
mais une date glissante hein quand même
parce que comme disait l'autre tous les
jours nous rapproche de la fin du monde
ce qui est vrai voilà une prédiction qui
risque pas d'être d'être contredite et
donc les téléprédicateurs qui
fonctionnent comme les télé les téléimam
les tél théologiens d'Égypte ou des du
golf et donc il vous font du discours
religieux avec des promesses avec des
explications des comportements sur la
vie quotidienne et cetera et puis
beaucoup de sites internet où on vous
promet les accompagnements bon par
exemple je cite un site internet qui
vous promet une visite du Paradis qui
est une une secte américaine il y a un
site internet qui vous vend islamiste
qui vous vend des centeurs du
paradis et si on paye en carte bleue on
obtient une réduction donc il y a des il
y a des tas de choses à découvrir quoi
internet offre permet une visite très
très bien organisée je peux vous poser
une question un peu plus personnelle
vous croyez en Dieu
je sais pas on sa'est jamais rencontré
le problème c'est qu'il s'est pas
beaucoup intéressé à moi donc j'en sais
rien quand vous savez la phrase de 68
qui disait dieu est mort signé Nietzsche
et le type avait écrit auudessous
Nietzsche est mort signé Dieu voilà on
est dans cette dans cette posture là
aujourd'hui un renouveau des religions
ce renouveau des religions il se fait
malheureusement selon des formes
sectaires pour beaucoup d'entre elles et
que cette forme sectaire sont des formes
incroyablement menaçantes pour la
démocratie et vous parlez de démocratie
euh à votre avis quce qui est en train
de se se mettre en place pour avoir un
dialogue avec ces PME auprès de l'État
l'état essaie d'avoir un dialogue avec
ses PME est-ce que vous pensez que ce
dialogue va être opérant est-ce que ce
dialogue à vos à votre sens est
inopérant vous avez des conseils
peut-être doné pluss il y a
plusieurs les pays démocratiques ont eu
plusieurs postures différentes hein pour
les Américains qui est par nature un
pays de refuge de toutes ces sectes qui
étaient persécuté en en Europe la le
principe de l'indépendance religieuse
est total c'est-à-dire que l'État se
refuse à avoir un quelconque discours
religieux ou à condamner quelque que ce
soit et la Scientologie est élevée au
rang de religion et la Scientologie est
reconnue comme une religion cela dit
reconnaître comme une religion ça veut
rien dire du tout aux États-Unis puisque
encore une fois il y a pas de statut des
religions c'est considéré comme une
entreprise les téléprédicateurs peuvent
faire des millions de dollars de de
recettes c'est pas considéré comme pour
nous si vous voulez de l'abus de
faiblesse dans le cas de la France c'est
un peu différent parce que dans le cas
de la France le gouvernement s'interdit
d'avoir un discours religieux il
considère simplement que pour le cas des
sectes par exemple ne sont condamnables
que des pratiques portant atteinte à des
droits individuels ça veut dire l'abus
de faiblesse ça veut dire le
détournement d'enfant des choses comme
ça ou l'emprise psychologique et cetera
et donc la mivilut qui est la mission
interministérielle de de veille contre
les dérives sectaires ne repose que sur
des pratiques condamnables au titre du
code pénal c'est tout mais pas au nom de
la liberté de religion
donc c'est très difficile on peut pas
discuter avec les sa encore une fois
vous savez faire descendre un
transcendant en lu faisant des leçons
d'instruction civique on n' pas beaucoup
eu de succès dans le domaine c'est
vrai j'aimerais que vous me lisiez la
phrase d'avantpros de votre livre
concernant la tolérance
h l'avantpros on est dessus page
9 je vous laisse
enchaîner ben ça c'est une phrase que
j'ai trouvé au cours de pérégrination
qui est une une phrase de Carl paupè
dans son bouquin sur la société ouverte
et ses ennemis dit si Onon est d'une
tolérance absolue même envers les
intolérants et qu'on ne défende pas la
société tolérante contre les assauts
contre leurs assauts les tolérants
seront anéantis et avec eux la société
tolérante je trouve que c'est une phrase
de bon sens c'està dire qu'effectivement
c'est ce que c'est un moment ce que
disait robesperre pas de liberté pour
les ennemis de la liberté donc il y a un
moment où effectivement la démocratie
cie les droits de l'homme la liberté de
parole trouve ses propres limites en
particulier quand on aboutit par exemple
à des pratiques sectaires qui sont des
pratique d'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme ou quand on aboutit à des appels
à la violence ou des appels au meurtrre
on est au 21e siècle est-ce que vous
pensez que notre société française est
plus ou moins tolérante je pense qu'elle
est beaucoup plus en tout état de cause
elle est beaucoup plus que tous les gens
qui la condamne en le prétendant
intolérante quand on entend j'aiécouté
l'autre fois dans une émission de radio
des interview fait en banlieu
ou des jeunes musulmans qui admiraient
quand même les attentats qui ont eu lieu
en janvier expliquai que leur plaisir
était d'aller leur désir serait d'aller
dans un pays musulman pour il vivre
librement leur religion quand
j'entendais le terme librement ça un
profond rire intérieur me déchirait
quand même parce que je parce que
définir la liberté en disant je vais
enfin pouvoirire librement ma religion
ils savent pas ce que c'est que l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est une plaisanterie vous
pouvez un peu développer sur l'Arabie
Saoudite bah l'Arabie Saoudite c'est un
espèce d'immense as pchiri théologique
c'est-à-dire il y a une il y a une
pratique de l'Islam qui est l'embalisme
qui est une la pratique la plus radicale
et la plus littérale si vous voulez de
la lecture du Coran qui a triomphé en
Arabie Saoudite au au début du 20e
siècle ENF pratiquement depuis le 18e
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle avec la
consécration à la fois de la dynastie
saoudienne et en même temps de la
pratique développée par Abdel Wahab qui
a développé le wahabisme bon quand vous
dites consécration de la famille Al
Saoud oui c'estàdire que le la famille
Al Saou Saou n'a pris pouvoir que par
cette association de pouvoir qui était
le pouvoir religieux et en même temps le
pouvoir de la Force et donc l'Arabie
Saoudite est un pays assez fantastique
dans lequel aucune autre religion n'est
autorisée où le la charia est appliquée
dans son sens le plus strict et le plus
bête là circule actuellement sur
Internet l'image de une vidéo de
décapitation d'une femme qui est une
pauvre fille venue du Myanmar hein donc
je vois les droits de la défense dans
devant le tribunal saoudien comment elle
a pu les exercer qu'on accusé d'avoir
maltraité ou d'avoir ir tuer sa
belle-fille je ne sais pas et elle est
exécutée sur un parking public avec des
gens qui tournent autour et cetera bon
je me dis fantastique si on défend
l'Arabie Saoudite contre l'État
islamique je doux dire qu'on va avoir un
match formidable donc on a un un il faut
s'imaginer ce que peut-être une ville
d'Arabie Saoudite une ville dans
laquelle il y a pas de cinéma il y a pas
de théâtre il y a pas de lieu culturel
si ce n'est d'aller à la mosquée et qu'
y a que des centres
commerciaux on peut se dire
qu'effectivement
euh la seule envie qu'on peut avoir
c'est de s'en aller bon le problème avec
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est quand Ben Laden
voulait exporter le modèle puisqueen
fait c'était un peu son idée même s'il
était en désaccord avec la famille Saou
mais en tout cas le modèle qui voulait
exporter c'était celui-là d'habitude
dans dans un asile psychiatrique le fou
il essaie de sauver pour trouver le
monde normal à l'extérieur lui il
voulait exporter le modèle donc c'est
quand même paradoxalement sur le plan
psychanalytique ça mériterait d'une
analyse et donc vous avez une société
dans laquelle les gens vivent les
apparence c'est-à-dire qu'ils font comme
s'ils étaient très bons pratiquants puis
dès qu'ils sont à l'extérieur vous avez
exactement le déchaînement de toutes les
pratiques les plus effroyables que
l'argent permet si vous voulez
prtitution et ca et C et puis évidemment
comme de toute façon en Arabie Saoudite
on trouve de l'alcool en connaissant les
bons réseaux de distribution on trouve
de la drogue et cetera vous avez des
problèmes d'alcoolisme et mais les
familles qui ont de l'argent envoie
leurs enfants pour désalcoolisation pour
cure de traitement antidrogue et cetera
dans des cliniques privées trèsupé en
Suisse c'est quand même là qu'on assure
l'anonyal plus complet pour ce genre de
chose donc on est dans une société qui
est totalement hypocrite mais qui a
beaucoup d'argent donc quand on est un
hypocrite qui a beaucoup d'argent il
faut faire attention si on veut de
l'argent il vaut mieux respecter son
hypocrisie si on veut être honnête on
dénonce son hypocrisie et et pour vous
pour vous le les plus hypocrites ce sont
les Saoudiens ou ceux qui traitent avec
les saoudien je sais pas parce que je
c'est quand même c'est une question
difficile hein vous savez quand Ben
Laden dans son programme de quand
l'époque où il voulait appliquer son le
le système qui le qu'on a découvert avec
les les attentats du 11 septembre il
avait désigné comme ennemi les
hypocrites alors je vous rassure les
hypocrites c'est pas vous et moi hein
les hypocrites parce que sinon il y
aurait plus personne à la surface de la
planète non les hypocrites c'est les
mauvais croyants les mauvais croyants
c'est-à-dire ceux qui croient pas comme
lui en l'occurrence c'était ça hein donc
si c'est la catégorie hypocrite au sens
Ben Laden du terme c'est une querelle
intramusulmane c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement il se massacre entre sunit
chiit entre entre alqïda et daesh et
cetera malheureusement on peut rien
faire pour eux ils vont découvrir au
bout d'un siècle que la tolérance c'est
aprô une vertu que le Coran n'enseigne
pas et que les autres grandes religions
monothéistes enseigignne pas mais enfin
faire on peut pas il faire grandchose
pour le reste c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on
peut négocier avec le diable ça fait des
siècles qu'on le fait ça fait des
siècles donc je sais pas si encore une
fois quand on négocie avec le diable il
faut une longue cuillère ça on est
d'accord mais encore une fois on y est
habitué
hein euh dernière question
avant dernière question quand quand
quand vous avez été amené à à discuter
de ce livre avec d' d'autres personnes
ayant à trait aux forces de l'ordre avec
l'armée ou
peut-être ça non non ça n' pas posé de
questions c'est pas de là que sont venus
les ennuis ce qui est rigolo c'est
qu'une fois j'ai été attaqué en
diffamation et vous devinerez jamais par
qui l'Église catholique non j'ai été
attaqué en diffamation par l'association
de défense des intérêts moraux de
l'Ordre du Temple solaire du Temple
solaire du mandarome pardon mandarome al
mandarome vous vous souvenez c'était
Gilbert Bourdin le type qui prétendait
tous les soirs se battre contre les
lémuriens je sais pas pourquoi les
lémurium enfin c'est ce qu'il disait
pour sauver la planète et donc vous
savez il avait construit ces immenses
statues en Provence là donc qui sont
restés là-bas puis ensuite il y a eu une
une action en justice qui a été entamée
contre lui notamment pour des pratiques
de pédophile et cetera et comme il est
mort trop tôt on n jamais su le fin m de
l'histoire bon toujours est-il qu' a une
association de défense des intérêts maux
du mondarom qui m'a un jour attaqué en
diffamation uniquement sur ce point
c'està-dire sur le fait que j'aiévoqué
les possibles pratiques pédophiles de
Gilbert Bourdin de son vrai nom et donc
en fait comme il y avait prescription
parce qu'en matière de diffamation la
prescription est très très très brève
bon ils se
sont en matière de diffamation il y a
deux techniques soit vous l'attaquez au
civil soit vous l'attaquez au pénal si
vous attaquez au civil vous vous
défendez sans avocat si vous attaquez au
pénal il faut prendre un avocat donc ils
ont essayé de me faire payer un avocat
c'est tout puis comme ils ont perdu à
cause de la forclusion ça s'est arrêté
là mais c'est pour dire que
contrairement à ce on peut penser les
réactions ne sont pas venu de ceux qu'on
penserait les plus attaqués peut-être
parce que justement ils sont même
divisés sur le sur leur propre
définition du paradis et des moyens d'y
accéder on va on va finir cette
interview par une dernière question si
vous aviez à laisser un conseil aux
jeunes
générations d'abord acheter mon livre ça
vous permettra de vous prémunir contre
les
excès de de toute nature de toutes les
certitudes qui vous sont infusées par
les uns ou par les autres ça c'est un
point absolument important ensuite je
dirais que la la phase de de Claudel je
crois que je cite à la fin qui dit que à
chaque fois que l'homme a voulu créer le
paradis sur terre il a surtout mener
directement à un enfer sur terre et
malheureusement tous les exemples que je
cite c'est-à-dire tous ces intégristes
qui ont voulu ici sur la planète créer
quelque part une espèce de paradis selon
les principes les plus obscurantistes
qu'on ait pu inventer que ce soit les
talibans à l'époque de Kabou que ce soit
Calvin à Genève
ou d'autres exemples de cette nature à
chaque fois ça a été un monde effroyable
de répression d'interdit d'interdiction
de la musique d'interdiction du jeu
d'interdiction de tas de choses de
répression sur les femmes donc à chaque
fois ils se sont réuni dans la la la
forme la plus effrayante de ce qu'on
peut imaginer êre l'enfer sur terre
juste une remarque pour terminer parce
que il y a quelque chose qui m'avait
frappé au moment des attentats du 11
septembre on avait trouvé dans la
chambre d'hôtel de Mohamed Atta euh le
leader du groupe euh une description de
ce qu'il pensait de ce qu'il croyait
l'attendre après sa mort et donc il
disait qu'effectivement euh il il aurait
donc dans le Paradis qui lui était
promis B il avait testé un petit peu
avant ah non c'est pas c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est-à-dire que il
savait que comme on lui avait promis il
attendait donc du vin qui ne saoule pas
et puis 72 vierges bon euh le problème
c'est que convaincu par les Saoudiens de
cette pratique terrible de l'Islam il
était à mon avis face à un problème de
schizophrénie profonde parce que si vous
imaginez que le vin et les femmes pour
un Saoudien c'est quand même les
États-Unis qui est quand même décrit
comme l'enfer sur terre et que par
contre l'enfer est décrit comme le
soleil le caillou et le désert
c'est-à-dire l'Arabie Saoudite cette
espèce de glissement d'image qui fait
que on a sur Terre ce qui doit ce qui
est décrit comme l'enfer et on a sur
Terre ce qui est décrit comme le paradis
l'Arabie Saoudite pour aller là-bas et
découvrir que le paradis c'est ce qui
est les États-Unis et puis l'enfer c'est
ce qui décrit l'Arabie saoudite a un
moment où les images si vous voulez
c'est comme le playback un moment où
l'image et le son se se recoupe pas je
sais pas comment il a résolu le problème
tu veux rajouter quelque chose non il y
a une histoire que j'ai trouvé très
bonne aussi c'est une histoire d'une
palestinienne il y avait un attentat
organisé avec deux femmes qui se
succédaient qui avaient chacune une
ceinture de de d'explosif et donc l'idée
c'était de faire comme souvent dans des
attentats c'est la première se faisait
exploser quand les services de secours
arrivaient porter remèes la seconde
devait faire exploser sa sa ceinture bon
or le souffle de l'explosion de la
première a assommé la seconde qui s'est
retrouvé s'est réveillé dans une chambre
toute blanche avec des gens qui
s'occupaient d'elle et cetera et qui la
soignit bon elle s'est dit je suis au
Paradis elle était équipée encore non
parce que à ce moment-là elle avait plus
son truc il l'avait démonté il avaiton
elle était dans une chambre toute
blanche avec des gens qui étaient autour
d'elle un médecin qui l'a soigné et
cetera donc elle s'est dit je suis au
Paradis les gens il ont dit non vous
nêtes pas au Paradis vous êtes pas mort
dit mais si le Paradis le paradis c'est
comme ça je vois bien il y a des gens
qui s'occupent de moi et le type le
médecin qui était là il essayit de la
convaincre elle voulait pas le convainc
finalement il a utilisé l'argument
suprême il a dit c'est pas le paradis
puisque je suis juif je suis médecin
juif et d'un seul coup pour elle c
écroulé si vous tout ce qui était la
description de son paradis donc voilà il
faut rester modeste face aux promesses
pierre connait ça merci Merci à
[Applaudissements]
VOUS MAJ bullshit
you
Allion
igion religion easily has the greatest
bullshit story ever told think about it
religion has actually convinced people
that there's an invisible
man living in the sky who watches
everything you do every minute of every
day and the invisible man has a special
list of 10 things he does not want you
to do and if you do any of these 10
things he has a special place full of
fire and smoke and burning and torture
and anguish where he will send you to
live and suffer and burn and choke and
scream and cry forever and ever till the
end of
time but he loves
you
you he loves you and he needs
money he always needs money he's all
powerful all perfect all knowing and all
wise somehow just can't handle
money religion takes in billions of
dollars they pay no taxes and they
always need a little more now you talk
about a good bullshit story holy
shit